louisville is close to firing two police
detectives for their roles in the
brianna taylor case taylor was killed in
a botched police raid in march
detective joshua james jans rather
obtained the search warrant but was not
present during the raid detectives miles
cosgrove
fired the shot that killed taylor we
spoke to an attorney for the taylor
family
who is asking for even stronger action
in an ideal world all of the officers
will be charged at this point
lawyer lanita baker represents brianna
taylor's mother tamika palmer
she says terminating the officers
responsible for the 26-year-old's death
is not enough at a minimum detective
jane should be charged with perjury
and mouse cosgrove with the murder of
brianna taylor
attorneys for both detectives confirmed
they received pre-termination letters
from louisville police
cbs news obtained a copy of jane's
letter signed by interim police chief
yvette gentry
she says he lied on the search warrant
application about having information
from a postal inspector
that taylor's ex-boyfriend had been
receiving packages
at taylor's apartment the ex-boyfriend
was the subject of a drug investigation
jane's lawyer thomas clay spoke to cbs
news by phone
these allegations against him are
unfounded
chief gentry also cites jane's role in
planning the raid
the letter states because the operations
plan was not completed properly
a very dangerous situation was created
for all parties involved
it was done with the full advice and
consent of the chain of command of the
louisville metro police department
it's unclear what cosgrove's letter
detailed but a police department source
tells cbs news
he is being fired for violating the
deadly force policy
cosgrove fired 16 shots into taylor's
dark apartment during the march raid
kentucky attorney general daniel cameron
says evidence showed he fired the fatal
shot
that killed taylor he couldn't hear
couldn't see but yet
he was firing both detectives are
scheduled for a hearing with gentry
a source also tells us three other
officers are expected to face
suspensions
and the only other officer involved in
taylor's death who was fired is brett
hakinson he was later indicted for
shooting
into a neighboring apartment that night
he has pleaded
not guilty you know this is a case that
we continue to cover
adriana you were down there i was down
there you've you know we've talked about
this story earlier but
uh it's it's not easy you know the
community is still hurting
uh and many people want answers it's so
i want someone to be held accountable
they do there's still a federal
investigation we should say so
where that leads thank you for the
update on the reporting yeah